tutti ragazzi venuti che sono vedere
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su chi mente
baku calvi manjit life è un gioco che
volevo fare da un pochettino perché in
età non è proprio un gioco tipo non ho
capito che il cazzo è chiaramente
interessa roba sarebbe un simulatore di
macchine nou dove tu praticamente scegli
la macchina imissu pessima non so perché
ma qualcosa dice in questa è la miglior
scelta che posso fare per ragazzi poiché
però fumo cannes ma perché ho deciso di
far star o l'aver il processo in un
miliardo di simulatori di macchine
perché non parte la porca [ __ ] di
macchina quindi fantastico ho acceso il
quadro accendere la mafia è in già in
start sventa è partita
ok bene fatto che non sapessi manco
partire ma meno meno meno si può
arrivare al menu il menu grazie il menu
no no no il bello perché appunto menù
come è perfetto
la cosa strana è la madonna ma cosa [ __ ]
e che quello che succede quello che
succederebbe davvero anche nella realtà
perché la fisica è al massimo
trame nell'acqua l'acqua non ha proprio
tutta sta gran fini che sembra tempo
turbo di smau sono molto più perché non
era non era prevista sarà di 776 starò a
ma io posso dare a fare le cose ma che
storia di fatte cambiare mattina
riprende questo mi fa cagare italia
autosport rally car ma è così perfetto
ma che storia attenzione è ma perché noi
italiani siamo sempre al top sulle mani
si guarda
la gravità zero non sapevo aiuto c'era
c'era una gravità zero o cavalcava cara
garino ok rai ha sfornato due macchine
in questo momento perché voglio provare
a fare una cosa che non so se mi riesce
procedevo provare assolutamente
porca vacca e cazzo è lesbica no no no
io no zio zio mi spaccato il nuovo
paraurti di mordacci lehto mar
me lo fate provare sito maledetto salto
senza che la gente mi ammazzi per
cortesia
porca vacca faccio così cagare a guidare
raga non c'è qualche problema
spero e prego il dio di non prendono mai
a valente mamma mi ha fatto faccio
pagare a guidare lega
vendiamo ops mi sa che mi sa che mi sa
che ci sono dei problemi
quando vado ancora come mio zio quanti
problemi con sesto vabbè vabbè come
possono farmi fare l'eroe che l'ormai o
che non so guida sono sono caduti in
piedi vale sono servivo va bene mi fate
guidare con cristiano normale per
cortesia e fin qua e fin qua ci siamo
per il resto è un problema
piano piano fiat veri geek manager
all'inizio proprio bene ma non potevo
pretendere chissà che cosa state le
scale e mio figlio siamo ragazzi prova
le scale che non open cup e pinelli non
è pirelli e pinelli fiore e pinelli bene
però credo che le macchine teoria
sappiano sopravvivere alle scalcia inter
questo è quello che succederebbe
realmente se una macchina provasse andar
giù dalle scale
in linea di massima
pensare neanche così male se alla fine
non ci fosse un palo
vorrei pensavo peggio la cosa [ __ ] che
veramente in teoria dovrebbe succedere
questo quindi mi sento un po come se
trovassi per la prima volta perché spero
che nessuno abbia mai fatto realmente ci
siamo ragazzi prevenuto facciamo qualche
test su cell su una pista tipo questa
che non è una pista ma è un livello solo
per farti agate mettevano così che però
non è neanche così male l'ataf chiaro
sono caduto in piedi va bene anche così
così scattare la madonna quella di prima
squadra lazio che prova a fare la serie
a porca vacca soligo vivo vivo iva e va
bene ok potete avere una macchina che
sia una macchina per l'amor di dio
fateli avere una macchina decente per
cortesia guarda che guarda perché faccio
pagare a guidare ma mica mi ha pure
andata a fuoco
non sono stato io era il mandala fuoco è
stata lei da sola per provare a
raggiungere tutti check point ragazza
ormai questione di vita o di morte
problema che non è così facile come
sembra che vede temi ok ok fino a qua
perfetto no
a caso
ogni volta che mi dicono che io vedo
male salvatevi questa parte del video
tranne questo pezzo che sta andando in
slow motion blur è che io credo che sia
meglio che stava dicendo sto dicendo che
credo che sia meglio out turbo di smau
per il semplice fatto che non gioco più
per bambini e più adatto a me perché se
io guido con le macchine non c'è verso
mi mettete e sapete cosa mi dà un sacco
di soddisfazione sapere che questo è un
simulatore realistico e che quindi io
veramente guidare così non diversamente
da quello che state vedendo quindi non è
male questa cosa giornale tipo gigi è il
simulatore vero che le macchine fanno
veramente quello che dovrebbero fare io
non ci andrò mai in macchina a fare la
spesa lo dico rare
rock insieme a 25 lo prende 5 ma tu sei
scemo valga drive no non è vero ma l'afa
culo per la cinematica addirittura
termica che casino è
[Musica]
mi sa che è meglio che metto la visione
giusta che vide ma porca vacca perché
riesca farsa curva il facilissimo orario
da 12 anni di videogiochi non possono
riuscire a fare questa cosa porca eva ok
ok ok stavate sono dove l'ultimo
checkpoint tutta una mia sorella
ora che due palle
beh ma guarda che secondo me è una
macchina così la puoi ancora usare la
puoi vendere la puoi usare come
fermaporta va bene che possiamo
concludere quali lei che basta perché
tanto vi avevo scaricato sto gioco
perché volevo fare volevo provare del
dei test di incidenti non ho altro da
aggiungere se non che pinelli cosa genio
riuscito il momento mi piace anche la di
società come il ct schianta i cibi
chiamato se un video dei ragazzi
[Musica]